mille - web adjoint au maire de cernay
dans le haut rhin en charge de la
sécurité de la politique des quartiers
bonsoir et mino et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le projet
de construction subventionné n'en finit
plus loin de faire réagir et le chrome
ont dit ces dernières heures d'abord la
justice saisit donc par la préfète
est-ce que c'est fondé selon vous cette
saisie pour demander l'annulation des
subventions
[Musique]
d'après cette étude entre aix et c'est
le patron et c'est le contrôle du de
l'égalité si effectivement le contrôle
de légalité désapprouvent
ça me paraît normal que que l'état en
face ceux ci mais après je pense qu'il
faut pas il faut pas faire un procès
d'intention à mairie du moins en tout
cas la mairie avait écologique de
strasbourg ils sont aux affaires que
depuis quelques mois
et très honnêtement ce projet vous avez
très bien qu'il existe deux purs mois
dix ans la pose de la première pierre a
été fait par un grande pompe par
l'ensemble des politiques que ce soit de
gauche ou de droite
après effectivement je pense qu'il faut
laisser faut laisser les faut laisser le
service instructeur et c'est
effectivement elle appartient à la
préfète de région en tout cas avec ses
services d'impression ou pas selon et
surtout de voir si effectivement le le
bleu la construction est tout à fait
conforme au permis qui a été délivré
tout ça c'est normal
cet examen se fera pas forcément dans un
climat très serein je vous laisse
regarder ce sondage un regard des 85%
des français qui désapprouve l'octroi de
cette subvention pour cette construction
de mosquées c'est une position qui est
tenable pour pour la mairie un désaveu
tant national que local
moi je moi je pense que certains projets
un lieu de culte il faut c'est hyper
important qu'il y ait des lieux de culte
j'ai envie de dire dans l'ensemble des
communes de france il faut que chaque
religion puisse exercer et faire
pratiquer sa religion
bien entendu est toujours sous couvert
des lois de la république sa cet
inconditionnel et ça ne se discute pas
les lois de la république d'abord
ensuite effectivement après une fois de
plus ça reste une volonté politique
d'une municipalité mais c'est vrai que
il faut pas non plus que je pense que la
mosquée de le projet en tout cas sur
strasbourg est un petit peu pharaonique
il faut pas non plus avec des minarets
de 35 m 50 m il faut aussi tête au ciel
mes pieds sur terre et son verbe et je
crois que c'est hyper important et ça
effectivement une fois de plus le permis
de construire est accordé par la
municipalité et qui est derrière
contrôlée par le contrôle de légalité
qui est les services de l'état entre
autres le préfet voir la préfète de
région
là on est on est dans le droit emil web
mais évidemment ce qui pose problème et
ça n'a pas échappé à l'intérieur c'est
évidemment que cette mosquée est financé
par une association qui n'a pas signé la
charte des principes de l'islam de
france inquiète attaché à la laïcité
quel est justement votre réaction ça
pose quand même un problème je crois
qu'ils servent que ministre de
l'intérieur il est l'île et garant il
est garant de la loi et la sécurité
publique et du si l'état si en tout cas
le métis de l'intérieur estime qu'une
association ne respectent pas les lois
de la république
il l'a fait comme il l'a fait un pas
vers d'errements de ma foi il faut
arrêter de discutailler il a le droit de
la dissoudre
si ce n'est pas le cas il faut arrêter
voilà je ne peux pas c'est pas c'est pas
moi d'apprécier si cette association et
après effectivement il ya dans le cadre
des financements il ya ce qu'on appelle
la traçabilité très fin et ceci et cela
dans le cadre des financements étrangers
et tout ce qui s'en suivent mais ça
reste un ça ne doit pas être un souci
politique mais ça devrait effectivement
toujours être en phase avec avec des
lois de la république qui doivent être
incontournable est toujours respectée
c'est un petit peu le rôle de l'ensemble
des élus en tout cas sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce qui met en lumière la
difficulté évidemment beaucoup parlé à
l'occasion de ce débat de conseillers
laïcité et concordants appelle cette loi
qui a lieu en alsace moselle qui permet
de subventionner les lieux de culte
clairement posé la question est ce que l
cité et loi du concordat sont elles
compatibles
aujourd'hui écoutez j'ai envie de vous
dire moi je suis je suis né en alsace
j'ai grandir l'alsace et j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir de la durant tout mon
école primaire une éducation avec les
soeurs et je peux vous assurer que je
regarde à 1 1
un souvenir particulier est toujours
très émouvant
voilà après jeu c'est un droit je crois
que c'est un droit alsacien c'est le
droit qui est reconnu effectivement
l'alsace moselle au concordat moi très
honnêtement moi j'y suis pour
et j'y suis particulièrement attachée
géant vite j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
que les alsaciens sont très
conservateurs très chauvin mais où en
tout cas moi j'en fais partie et
particulièrement fiers donc moins pour
moi le concordat ne devrait pas en tous
les cas changer ben en tout cas ce genre
d'affaires voilà entraîne une forme de
pas de suspicion mais c'est vrai que 78%
des sondés contre sont contre le
concordat à l'échelle nationale on va
voir peut-être sur sur le sondage qui va
s'afficher regarder 78% des sondés ça
fait beaucoup et seulement effectivement
52% des accusations dont vous faites
partie qui sont favorables à
l'abrogation de de ce régime
justement quand il s'agit de deux
mosquées financées par des associations
voient là où il ya une forme de
suspicion parce qu'elles n'ont pas signé
la charte de l'islam est ce que ça peut
fragiliser et ce sera ma dernière
question ce concordat auxquels sont très
attachés les alsaciens non mais je crois
pas que il faut pas que ce peuple que
cette polémique en tout cas avec cette
mosquée sur strasbourg ne doit pas
il faut pas que ce soit l'arbre qui
cache la forêt je veux dire nous le
concordat pour l'instant le compara
c'est toujours très très bien placé
passé en alsace dont la preuve des
alsaciens sont plus que fier mais
maintenant ce problème avec cette
mosquée strasbourgeoise ne doit pas
remettre en tous les cas en question le
concordat dont la masse je reste
intimement convaincu la majorité des
alsaciens isis ont trait à passer en
tout cas hemingway vas tu m'emmerdes de
cerner en charge de la sécurité de la
politique des quartiers merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous